that was a look at his new Netflix movie
The Curse of bridge Hollow I love this
movie I love it yes I watch it with my
kids
um you've done a few scary movies do you
like scary movies like why this one I
well this one is different most of my
scary movies I'm glad when you said I
watched it with my kids this is one of
the first movies I've ever done probably
in my career of doing horror comedy and
you can actually watch it with your kids
they loved it but that was a good thing
scary movie you can't watch that with
your kids I'm sure some people it's
fluids everywhere you'll be answering
all kinds of questions same thing with
haunted house haunted house I was with a
doll and doing all kind of crazy stuff
and you can't watch that with your kids
but this one is actually appropriate and
it's a good family movie and I really
like it great special effects I love
that so wait that you've said that your
family though didn't do Halloween when
you were younger no my dad was Joe
witness so oh so you didn't yeah me and
my brother we still did it we just now
had no costumes like my dad wouldn't
participate so I would dress up like
Sean and Sean would dress up as me
and they'd be like who are you I'm Sean
he's Molly
we was just baking basically it was like
I just wanted some money and some free
candy
something you really did Halloween like
dressed up uh
uh I think I probably when I was like
30s when I had kids it was when I did my
first what what about your 20s no I I my
dad was still in my ear you know what I
mean so I still felt like he could spank
me you seen how skinny I was
but what about that what's my dad
I'm celebrating Halloween sit your
because my dad was out of shape then and
so I was like I could take you and I was
it was funny because I wanted to look
good in Halloween I wouldn't be in no
costume so I was Run DMC every year for
like 10 years because he was throwing a
dope Adidas tracksuit and you got your
glasses your gazelles and you hit that
pose and you fly you know what I mean I
know I go to the opposite I go like
weird like I want to be like Beetlejuice
like I go the opposite that's a good one
I know it's just I like it you shrink
your head
and admitted anonymity I can't say it
anonymity there you go I because I go
out with my kids trick-or-treating and
nobody knows who I am so that's kind of
fun that's dope because everybody I've
been famous so long I can't put on a
costume they're like look at Marlon
Wayans that's Beetlejuice
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]